you said something that triggered my
memory of two different interviews I saw
with artists and both those artists came
from a small town and they said where
they came from had very supportive like
a very supportive Network however it was
never okay to try to rise above the
group because if you did then they said
oh you think you're better than us so
can you talk about that because I think
it's a very real part of people's
upbringing or or their they have a great
support system
but there is an unspoken or maybe spoken
thing where oh you don't want to act
like yours to better than us or smarter
than us or who do you think you are to
do this over us and have just the normal
life that we have back here in our small
town okay let me say this I don't get
that because most of the people that are
close to me that are friends from home
or whatever they know what I've gone
through and the struggles I've had and
it's kind of funny that I'm being
serious they whatever resentment they
might have for me they don't bring it to
me because they know what I've been
through I mean I literally I literally
was on foot for a number of years where
my car I had old beat-up cars and
whatnot because my music lessons my
voice lessons I would study my first
well I had a teacher before the man I
got she had me come once a week and I
couldn't really sustain what she was
teaching me you know as far as my vocal
training and when I got with mr. Harris
he said let me tell you something you've
got to come at least two or three times
a week
he says cuz I got to build this voice up
I got a bill your this whole thing up so
I said well wasn't I supposed to be
singing from a little that mask and
using my diaphragm he says yeah he said
but still got to come through your
throat yes so we got to build that up
he says and I want you to come and check
me out he's a sing himself and check
some of my people out at this concert we
give him well I went and I was like wow
so he said it's not cheap so you got to
make up your mind as far as how much you
want to spend and how much you really
want to do this so it became a point
where I was catching buses and and and
standing at the bus stops and sub-zero
and freezing like this you know and my
friends and people that were close to me
knew this and saw me saw me and my first
fiance hey whatever you want to call it
my teacher had lived not far from her
and I was standing at a bus stop and you
know the bus stall and I saw her cart it
was uh it was like a Kentucky Fried she
loved chicken it was a Kentucky Fried
Chicken behind where I was at I'm
standing here on the street and bus star
like this and it was a Kentucky Fried
Chicken meow and I saw her car I've set
the in saw her car go through the
drive-thru at the Kentucky Fried Chicken
and it comes out on the side where I am
he goes in it goes in this way and it
goes around right and it comes out this
way on this side of me and I'm standing
here like this and I literally know knew
that she and her sister or somebody in
the car were like looking at me and I
didn't look over cuz it was a point
where I was like okay this is who I am
and this is what I got to do they drove
off that was that was that was that was
a hard thing for me to deal with that
was a hard thing for me to deal with but
I said okay you know this is what I have
to deal with and and so people that I
said that we're close to me my parents
and sisters and good friends I never got
them from them because they knew and
they still know what I'm going through
so if nothing else they say man
Wow I have people that are really
impressed with the fact that I've been
doing this this long and I've been fired
a couple times in this too but you
always go to the next job but well but
they've been impressed with the fact
that I've done this this long and I make
it a nice living bleed me and people I
run into I haven't seen in years say wow
you're doing that that's hard in it I
said well look at me this look like I
lost any meals oh they said yeah you
have put on the weight I said yeah I say
you don't put on away from not eating if
you put away from eating I said so I'm
doing pretty good you know and and I
don't say this to anybody or anything
but over the last 10 whatever years I
paid more money per you for you to nail
on me
I mean lot more but I don't carry myself
like that and I don't maybe one reason
why they don't have a real problem with
me is because I don't carry myself
pumpless anything anybody that sees me
that I knew coming up from school or I
run into somewhere or whatever they say
you still the same I said yeah because
I'm secure and Who I am and I don't have
to pretend to be something or I don't
have to put on airs because this is just
what I do I said this is my life this is
my my job ok this is what I do so I
don't feel this any more important than
any more special than what you do and
and I treat people like that I'm like oh
I'm happy my niece wanted to get into
this and she's like I don't I said look
just cuz I'm in this and you like what
I'm doing if this is not for you do what
do what you do and do you come on you
money I love you you like my little
child
I'm mmm do you I said I don't want to
see you suffering this she's got a
regular job doing
quite well I'm like I do you I don't I
don't care what you do as long as you do
you and you happy doing you then you're
a success see you you you people say
well I don't feel successful at what why
you doing you you you got a job you got
a house you got this you got whatever
you happy in what you do you look well
you're doing well that's success
it doesn't matter how much money you
make it it's what you do that makes you
happy and and what you are good at doing
and you doing it you know it's just what
it is you have to be you I keep
stressing that over and over you have to
do you you can't be something that
somebody else wants you to be it'll
never work you end up wanting yeah shoot
him or whatever jump off the damn top of
the building or something I had a friend
do that by the way and then but but you
you got it you got to be you and and I
don't I don't I don't let people trip on
me about you know the fact that you know
I'm better because I don't come off like
that I don't come off like that with
anybody I give people advice on the
business
I help people I'm not gonna give him a
thousand dollars I mean you know I mean
man I'm giving money to my family much
more than that because that's my family
I've given some friends you know stuff
like that but not just not a random
woman that you know got on a nice outfit
and kind of high heels and you know look
good I'm like come on I mean I've been
with good-looking women my whole life
I've always even when I was sighs in the
first grade I thought I was suave and
debonair when I had my lunch pail with
Roy Rogers you know sitting on it I'm
like yeah that's the Roy Rogers lunch
meal you know I mean I've always been
beautiful women that's just me and
that's not so beautiful you know but but
it's like it's just the way it is you
know so I don't let that trip I don't
know test them get to me you know